this is indigo
real indigo
jeans they're dyed from a chemical but
real indigo straight from the plant has
its roots in samurai culture and it's
highly prized in japan
yep this story is all about the real
color blue
but it's not as dull as it sounds
[Music]
tokushima japan is located in the
southwest of the country and for
centuries it has been known for its
indigo due to the yoshinogawa river
which flows underground warming the soil
indigo started gaining popularity in the
early 1600s and was commonly used by
samurais
[Music]
[Music]
real indigo was also used for
firefighters clothing because it's flame
retardant up to 1500 degrees fahrenheit
to produce indigo ink the leaves must be
harvested and then dried in the sun and
flipped repeatedly with a broom until
they turn a navy heal
[Music]
because of this osamu is one of the last
five indigo growers in the region the
practice is time consuming and labor
intensive so former growers have turned
to cheaper chemical alternatives but the
thing is with real indigo the color you
can achieve is unparalleled
this is toshiharu frucho he's a fabric
dyer
you know
[Music]
he is able to pull out an incredible
range of blues from the natural ink from
a nearly black blue they called nando
ero to deep ocean hues called kachiro
achieving these colors though is not
easy
[Music]
his commitment to his craft can be seen
in his hands his nails are eternally
stained blue from nearly 50 years of
working with the dye
[Music]
and osamu he's not hanging his trial yet
up either yep
[Music]
chicago
[Music]
you